hello there internet it's me john oliver
look our show is still on hiatus right
now but i wanted to come back briefly to
talk to you about something that
something is
snacks guys
i'm a snack fiend i love all those salty
crunches and fizzy sippums they're
crinkly bags and shiny bottles i don't
even mind that they're all nutritionally
bankrupt and tastes like red dye number
40. taste is just one of the senses and
honestly it's overrated
my complaint is with snack companies
specifically how they caught the youth
camping out on twitter spamming whatever
the current hot meme is like when
everyone decided to tweet red flag
statements along with red flag emojis it
started like most good things online on
black twitter and from there it
proceeded directly to hell with chips
ahoy tweeting i don't like chocolate
chip cookies red flags pringles tweeting
i don't stack my hashtag pringles flags
captaincrunch tweeting i like my cereal
soggy and pop-tarts tweeting when they
boil pop-tarts there were many many more
of these all of which deserve
conservatively life in prison
but the thing is this is what brands do
now they hang out on twitter
regurgitating memes and occasionally
pretending to have a mental health
crisis like when sonny d tweeted simply
i can't do this
anymore
and pop tarts responded can i please
offer you a hug we are gonna get through
this together my friend an exchange
which i'm pretty sure just gave me
actual depression
and you might be thinking well hold on
hold on
what should snack brands be doing john
oliver while you sit there judging them
in your ivory tower and your fancy tie
and your haircut someone tried really
hard on well
i'll tell you what they should be doing
because they already did it back in the
1990s when and this is true they made
video games yeah brands like 7up the
poor man sprite and the rich man sierra
missed
made games starring their almost
poetically lazy mascot cool spot they
took the spot from their logo gave it
cool sunglasses and called it cool spot
art there was the game cool spot spot
the video game spot the cool adventure
and 1995's spot goes to hollywood and
the crazy thing is
some of those games were pretty decent
here's cool spot jumping around a beach
here he is bouncing around a soda bottle
and here he is trying to murder a mouse
in pajamas look he was a great example
of a brand transcending its origins in
this case seltzer that a lime sneezed in
and becoming something truly great and
importantly 7up was not alone on this
cheetos released chester cheetah too
cool to fool and it's remarkable that
grown-up executives sat around a table
at cheeto hq and signed off on a video
game that they thought might sell their
desiccated cheese poops and he's
thinking but john steady on
of course cheetos and 7up made video
games their mascots already look like
video game characters a less extreme
snack brand would never make one hey hey
hey hey chex quest
in 1996
checks
made a video game
the child's am disappointment
the party mistake the cereal that comes
in flavors of wheat rice and corn even
though all three taste like the box it
came in that
chex
licensed the game engine from
doom
at the height of the shooter video game
moral panic and made a game that looked
like this with absolutely non-stop
violence putting copies of it in boxes
off and this best repeating checks
cereal
and their only attempt at making this
relevant two checks was switching the
hero with a corn square which raises the
question
why
why did checks do that we wanted to make
a first person shooter game that
could fit in a cereal box because we
knew that's what the kids would want six
million copies in six million box of
cereal they were gone in six weeks and
chex cereal sales went up 248
czech cereal was happening
it's true
for six weeks in 1996 czech serial
and that it's true
that is the transformational reality
bending quality video games could bring
to boring brands around the world today
oh and if you're wondering just how a
serial company turned around a video
game in record time they found a helpful
little trick we found the most
brilliant
secret weapon on the planet his name is
scott holman he was 17 in high school
the company's sitting and waiting for 3
30 it's like oh we can't start until
school's out school gets out he starts
programming he works until 11 30. if you
talk to a professional
they will tell you why you can't get it
done
but if you need to get it done anyway
look for a teenager
okay uh
child labor laws aside
[Applause]
if you need to get it done look for a
teenager he's just not a good adage
if you need someone to explain tick-tock
to you look for a teenager is better if
you need someone to say something
casually mean about you when you're
passing them in the street that will
live in your brain until the day you die
look for a teenager that is better still
and look at this stage i feel i've
pretty much proven my point here which i
think was something about how snack
video games were both stupid and
spectacular no more examples needed and
yet i have another one for you
pepsi man
pepsi man yes pepsi man that is a real
game that human beings made they even
made cover art which i can only describe
as what if an aluminum can was a power
top
guaranteed 100
this thing comes pepsi incidentally
don't look that up don't google horny
pepsi man don't do that look at me i'm
trying to protect you don't do that
pepsi man was a japan exclusive game and
was essentially temple run except you're
a pepsi themed superhero saving people
with pepsi but that barely describes the
rich narrative at play
it looks like the main computer of pepsi
city went out of control a little while
ago from being overloaded there isn't
enough pepsi for everyone and violence
has flared up amongst those wanting
pepsi
exhausted people are collapsing because
they can't refresh themselves with pepsi
what
i mean that clip has everything you
could ever want a cop saying the word
pepsi too many times
the main computer of pepsi city and the
word amongst and at this point
i would love to show you that between
levels there are clips of a
stereotypical american chugging pepsi
and shouting at you about how good pepsi
is i would love to do that so you know
what
i will
you got it yeah
yeah
everybody pepsi drink pepsi
look
i'm glad that guy exists but also
screaming drink pepsi
you're talking to someone that just
played a pepsi video game to completion
relax buddy i think you got him here
look all of this is really just a very
long way of asking what happened snack
brands around 25 years ago you cracked
the code of turning commercials the
thing everyone hates into video games
the thing everyone loves i don't want to
see quiznos tweeting when the sandwich
isn't toasty or whatever the i want
them to put me in the pilot seat of a
16-bit spaceship shaped like a hoagie
that fires beef lasers at alien vegans
that's what i want
the point here is snack foods should
tweet less and make games more think of
the world that we could live in we could
have orville redenbacher space marine or
chips ahoy but your grizzled cookie
pirates sailing a sea of milk trying to
track down captain crunch and nail his
seven head to your mast i'll give you
i'll give you one more just off the top
of my head a fighting game but the only
characters are spaghettio and chef
boyardee
like mortal kombat but crucially no
music
no one claps no one cheers an arena full
of faces what's the brutal ballet in
silence this is not entertainment
there's no glory here there is only what
must be done bones crack
pasta splits there's tomato sauce
everywhere
and when one mascot lies broken at the
victor's feet
that fallen character is permanently
dead the game cannot be played again
this is life
there are no do-overs
i mean that's just three free slam dunk
ideas
that any brand can have right now so
companies
log off twitter
and make something interesting you
vampires
that's it from me i'm gonna go convince
my staff to put me in a video game on
the grounds that i am at least as
entertaining as czech's cereal
rice chex that is not corn chex i could
never thank you so much for watching we
will be back in february until then
goodbye
you